megan congratulations we just have to
get this out the way i guess you have
found out that rook b2 would have drawn
the game here as you created a stalemate
to her king yeah i actually missed this
so it was a sort of a surprise and nice
that she didn't end up seeing it
in indeed a big win against her tell us
about the game itself where did she mess
where did she make her errors um i think
she's not usually a d6 like g6 player so
she was a little unfamiliar with the
opening setup
and i think
where i had to push d5
she
might have
tried to trade queens but i think um
yeah it was a pretty tough situation i
think if i didn't play d5 she would play
d5 and then she would get some counter
play with c5
um
it looked like she was getting play in
this game
like it was equal-ish at some point
and then all of a sudden you won i
looked over and you were up two pawns
how did that happen
um i think she was trying to complicate
things in time trouble so
um she sacrificed a few pawns on the
queen side
to try to maybe try to get a checkmate
going so here it's still even material
where was the sacrifice
um i think i think she might have missed
when i played knight before
if he moves
a few moves forward um
when she played rook c5
after my i went rookie one that i could
play
um knight d3 so then i think she dropped
that
those retreating moves we always talk
about them nasty so that was pawn number
one
and then you just clipped pawn number
two okay that's how you you got the two
pawns
and then that little little hiccup in
the middle of the technique uh have you
ever
drawn a game because of stalemate in
your career um maybe when i was younger
yeah
like six
yeah i think there was one game at
nationals some i had two queens against
me and he stalemated me okay
could have been another brutal shower in
this one well congratulations on your
win and good luck tomorrow
congratulations